in the flame and blood and destruction
of Pearl Harbor there began on December
7 1941 the most momentous year in all
the annals of the American Red Cross a
year in which the Red Cross has met with
high honor the supreme test of its
history the Red Cross was ready at Pearl
Harbor aiding Army and Navy medical
staffs Red Cross workers were on hand
with the sorely needed reserves of
surgical dressings and supplies and the
boys of the life-saving blood plasma
which it had been collecting and storing
for months throw combined efforts of
doctors nurses and Red Cross more than
ninety six percent of pearl harbors
wounded were saved
from Washington the national
headquarters of the American Red Cross
are directed the activities of a vast
and expanding field organization who
stupendous war task undertaken at the
request of the Army and Navy is to look
out for the welfare of millions of men
in America's armed forces to serve each
individual soldier or sailor as friend
and advisor and as a link with the folks
back home as well as to help solve the
personal problems and ease the worries
of convalescence in hundreds of Army and
Navy hospitals
backbone of the American Red Cross are
it's 30 million members citizens of
every community on the land surgical
dressings are being turned out at the
rate of 500,000 an hour by volunteers of
the Red Cross production core
to those held as prisoners of war have
gone a million packages of food and
other supplies or distribution through
the International Red Cross at Geneva
the volunteer MotoCorp whose personnel
is made up host entirely of women has
been tripled since Pearl Harbor in
hundreds of out of the way posts and
stations its members augment the work of
the canteen Corps by providing special
and welcome comforts for servicemen on
duty
delegated with the responsibility of
enrolling three thousand nurses a month
for service in the Army and Navy the Red
Cross is meeting the inevitable shortage
of nurses on the homefront by training
100,000 nurses aides to take over
Hospital routine another red cross
function is the teaching of first aid
and home nursing to millions of US
citizens outstanding project of the red
cross on the home front is its blood
donor service the largest undertaking in
all medical history the army and navy
had called upon the Red Cross for an
increased quota of 4 million pints of
blood in 1943 which means that more than
75,000 donations must be collected each
week the junior Red Cross has produced
half a million garments for refugee
children and turned out 3 million items
like comfort kits and games for American
fighting men with the embarkation of the
first of the new American Expeditionary
Forces the Red Cross was called upon to
assume a new responsibility to provide
for the welfare and recreation of huge
armies of Americans on duty and strange
lands far from home today and countless
combat areas around the world the Red
Cross has set up its field offices here
a serviceman can take his problems to
the field director for help and advice
to carry on all the diversified
activities of the Red Cross requires
feel directors whose personal qualities
can commend the confidence and respect
of the men almost anywhere Americans are
stationed they can find through the Red
Cross the kind of entertainment they
like best
in dozens of foreign cities the Red
Cross has taken over whole hotels and
converted them into clubs like the famed
George Washington Club in London where
American servicemen can find
companionship and hospitality
in whatever part of the world the
American serviceman finds himself nearby
there is likely to be a club where he
can get a room and breakfast for less
than fifty cents and where he can spend
his days of leave cheaply and pleasantly
nothing is more important to the morale
of our fighting men and the Red Cross
home service which acts as a friendly
medium of communication with families
back home since Pearl Harbor trained Red
Cross workers have given help or advice
in a million and a half cases best
fitted to tell what the Red Cross means
two men on the fighting fronts are those
who know from experience if you want to
know what the Red Cross does for
servicemen just ask any submarine center
when we get back to some foreign port
after weeks on patrol it's pretty swell
to be able to drop into a Red Cross Club
and have some fun I'm gonna carry in the
South Pacific I got hit by a bomb
fragment and I wouldn't be here now if
it wasn't for the blood plasma of the
Red Cross collected I was on Guadalcanal
for almost five months first few weeks I
used to worry about my family a lot I
hadn't heard from him but the man from
the Red Cross got in touch with him for
me and I found out my wife had the baby
we expected okay eight pounds both to
and fine another who knows from
experience what the Red Cross means is
JB Powell an American newspaper man who
lost both his feet in a Japanese prison
you'd have to spend six months in a
Japanese internment camp as I did to
understand what it means to men in enemy
prison camps when letters and packages
of food and medicines arrived through
the Red Cross if the Red Cross never did
anything but that it still would have
earned all of the gratitude all of the
praise and all of the support we
Americans can give it with pride in its
record since Pearl Harbor the Red Cross
submits its report on its first year of
war
and pledges itself that in the future
wherever it may be needed to serve the
armed forces in the Mediterranean or the
Pacific or at home in Africa the Far
East or Europe there will be found the
American Red Cross